so you've been obsessed with this
problem for the last few years what is
the problem in your own words plastic
simple as that our inability to use it
for the tremendous energetic commodity
death that it is and just throw it away
and so we see waste everywhere at its
extreme it looks a bit like this I mean
where where was this picture taken
that's in the Philippines and you know
there's a lot of rivers ladies and
gentlemen which look exactly like that
that's the Philippines so it's all over
Southeast Asia so plastics thrown into
the rivers and from there of course it
ends up in the ocean I mean we obviously
see it on the beaches but that's not
even your main concern it's what's
actually happening to it in the oceans
talk about that yeah okay so look thank
you Chris
about four years ago I um thought I'd do
something really barking crazy and I I
committed to do a PhD in marine ecology
and it's scary part about that was sure
learned a lot about marine life but it
taught me more about marine death and
the extreme mass ecological fatality of
fish of marine life marine mammals very
close to apology to us which dying in
their millions if not trillions that we
can't count at the hands of plastic but
people think of plastic as ugly but
stable right you throw something in the
ocean hey it'll just sit there forever
can't do any damage right yeah say Chris
it's it's an incredible substance
designed for the economy it is the worst
substance possible for the environment
the worst thing about plastically as
soon as it hits the environment is that
it fragments it never stops being
plastic it breaks down smaller and
smaller and smaller and
the breaking science on this Chris which
we've not in marine ecology for a few
years now but it's going to hit humans
you know we are aware now that nano
plastic the very very small particles
are plastic carrying their negative
charge can go straight through the pores
of your skin
that's not the bad news the bad news is
that it goes straight through the
blood-brain barrier that protective
coating which is there to protect your
brand your brains a little amorphous wet
mass full of little electrical charges
you put a negative particle into that
particularly negative particle which can
carry pathogens so you have a negative
charge it attracts positive charge
elements like pathogens toxins mercury
lead that's the break in science we're
going to see in the next 12 months so
already I think you told me that there's
there's like 600 plastic bags or so for
every fish that size yeah in the ocean
something like that and it's and it's
and it's they're breaking down and
there's gonna be ever more of them and
we haven't even seen the start of the
consequences of that no we really
haven't looked good the the team at the
Ellen MacArthur Foundation a bunch of
good scientists we've been we've been
working with them for a while I'd
completely verify their work they say
there'll be one ton of plastic crisps
for every three ton of fish by not 2050
right I really get impatient with people
who talk about 2050 by 2025 that's
around the corner that's just a here and
now you don't need one ton of plastic
completely wipe out marine life you know
less than that is going to do it a fine
job at it so if you know we have to end
it straightaway we've got no time okay
so you have an idea for ending it and
you're coming at this not as a typical
environmental campaigner I would say but
as a as a businessman as an entrepreneur
who has lived you've spent your whole
life thinking about global economic
systems and how they work and if I
understand it right your your idea
depends on heroes who look something
like this what's her profession she
chris is a ragpicker
and there were 15 20 million ragpickers
like her until china stopped taking
everyone's waste
the price of plastic minuscule that it
was collapsed that led to people like
her which now she is a child who is a
school child she should be at school
that's probably very keen to slavery
my daughter Gracie and I've met hundreds
of people like her and there are many
adults as well literally millions around
the world and in and in some industries
they actually account for the fact that
for example we don't see a lot of metal
waste in the world oh that's exactly
right that that little girl is in fact
the hero of the environment she's in
competition with a great big
petrochemical plant which is just down
the road the three and half billion
dollar petrochemical plant that's the
problem
you know we've got more falling gas in
plastic and landfill then we have in the
entire oil and gas resources of the
United States so she is the hero and
that's what that landfill looks like
ladies and gentlemen and it's solid oil
and gas so there's this huge value
potentially locked up in there that the
world's ragpickers would if they could
make a living from but why why can't
they because we have ingrained in us a
price of plastic from fossil fuels which
sits just under what it takes to
economically and profitably recycle
plastic from plastic see all plastic is
is building blocks from oil and gas you
know it's a plastics 100% polymer which
is 100 percent oil and gas and you know
we've got enough plastic in the world
for all UNAIDS and when we recycle
plastic if we can't recycle it it
cheaper than fossil fuel plastic then of
course the world just sticks to fossil
fuel plastic so that's the fundamental
problem the price of recycled plastic is
is usually more than the price of just
buying it straight made fresh from more
oil that's the fundamental problem there
a slight tweak of the rules here Chris
I'm a commodity person I understand that
you know we used to have scrap metal and
rubbish iron and bits of copper lying
all around the villages particularly in
the developing world they
people worked out it's got a value it
it's an actually an article of value
it's not a waste
now the villages and the cities and the
streets are clean you don't see you
don't trip over scrap copper scrap iron
now because it's it's an article of
value it gets recycled so what's your
idea then - to try to change that in
plastics okay so Christopher most part
of that PhD I've been doing research and
the good thing about being a business
person who's done OK at it is that
people want to see you you know other
business people even if the kind of
benefits do animal species they'd like
to check out so yeah ok well well I met
Twiggy forest and and so once you're in
there you can interrogate them and and
I've been to most of the oil and gas and
fast-moving consumer good companies in
the world and there is a real will to
change I mean there's a couple of
dinosaurs who are going to hope for the
best and do nothing but there's a real
will to change so what I've been
discussing is that the 7 part billion
people in the world don't actually
deserve to have their environment
smashed by plastic their oceans rendered
the portrait or Baron of the sea life
because of plastic so you come down that
chain and there's tens of thousands of
brands which we all buy heaps of product
from but then there's only a hundred
major resin producers pet big
petrochemical plants that spew out all
the plastic which is single-use so 100
companies are right at the base of this
food chain is it that yeah and so what
what do you need those 100 companies to
do okay so we need them to simply raise
the value of the building blocks of
plastic from oil and gas which I call
bad plastic raise the value of that so
that when it spreads through the brands
and onto us as customers we won't barely
even notice an increase in our coffee
cup or Coke or Pepsi or anything like
what like a Sun extra s less you know
court of sent half cent its will be
absolutely my absolute minimal but what
it does it makes every bit of plastic
all over the world an article of value
it you know where where you have the
waste worst say Southeast Asia India
that's where the wealth is most okay so
if it feels like there's two parts to
this one is by if they can if they will
charge more money but carve out that
excess and pay it into what into a fund
accelerated by someone to tackle this
problem of what what would that money be
that may be used for though they charge
the extra for so so when I speak to
really big business I said like I need
you to change and I need you to change
really fast they're gonna their eyes are
gonna peel over and boredom unless I say
and it's good business okay now I've got
my attention Andrew so say right I need
you to make a contribution to an
environmental and industry transition
funder over two or three years the
entire global plastics industry can
transition from getting its its building
blocks from fossil fuel to get ex
building blocks from plastic there
technologies out there it's proven I've
taken two multi-billion dollar
operations from nothing recognizing that
the technology can be scaled I see at
least a dozen technologies in plastic to
handle all types of plastic so once
those technologies have an economic
margin which this gives them that's
where the public the global public will
get all their plastic from from existing
plastic so every sale of virgin plastic
contributes money to a fund that is used
to basically transition the industry and
start to pay for things like clean up
another pieces sorry
absolutely so and it has the incredible
side benefit which is maybe even the
main benefit of creating a market it
suddenly makes recyclable plastic a
giant business that can unlock millions
of people around the world to find a new
living collecting it yeah exactly so I
mean all you do is you've got fossil
fuel Plastics at this value and recycled
plastic this value you change it so
recycle plastic is cheaper what I love
about this most Chris is that you know
we've we waste into the environment 300
350 million tons of plastic on the oil
and gas company's own accounts it's
going to grow to 500 million tons this
accelerating problem but every tonne of
that is polymer polymer is $1,000 $1,500
a time
that's half a trillion dollars which
could go into business and could create
jobs and opportunities and wealth right
across the world particularly in it the
most impoverished yet we throw it away
so this would allow the big companies to
invest in recycling plants literally all
over the world where the plan is over
the world because the technologies low
capital cost you can put it rubbish
dumps bottom the big hotels garbage
their place everywhere turn that waist
into resin now you're a philanthropist
and you're ready to commit some of your
own wealth to this what is the role of
philanthropy on this project I think
what we have to do is kick in the 40 to
50 million US dollars to get it going
and then we have to create absolute
transparency so everyone can see exactly
what it's got going on from the resin
producers to the brands to the consumers
everyone gets to see who's playing the
game who's protecting the earth and who
doesn't care and that'll cost about a
million dollars a week and we're going
to underwrite that for five years total
contributions circa 300 million US
dollars
well now and it you've talked to other
companies like to the cover colors of
this world who are willing to do this
they willing to pay a higher price they
would like to pay a higher price so long
as it's fair yeah it's fair so coca-cola
wouldn't like Pepsi to play ball unless
the whole world knew that Pepsi wasn't
playing ball then they don't care so
it's that transparency of the market
where you know if people try and cheat
the system the market can see that the
consumers consent consumers want a role
to play in this seven half billion is we
don't want our well smashed by a hundred
companies so tell us um you said what
the companies can do and what you're
willing to do what what can people
listening do okay so I would like all of
us all around the world to go to a
website called no plastic waste you
contact your hundred resin producers
which in your region you'll have at
least one within an email or a Twitter
or you know a telephone contact from you
and let them know that you
I came to make a contribution to a fund
which industry can manage or the World
Bank can manage it raises tens of
billions of dollars per year so you can
transition the industry to getting all
its plastic from plastic not from fossil
fuel we don't need that that's bad this
is good and it can clean up the
environment you've got enough capital
there got tens of billions billions of
dollars crisp per annum to clean up the
environment you're in the recycling
business isn't this a conflict of
interest for you or rather a huge
business opportunity for you yeah look I
I'm in the iron ore business and I
compete against the scrap metal business
and that's why you don't have any scrap
lying around to trip over and and and I
cut your toe on get directed this isn't
your excuse to go into the plastic
recycling business no I'm I am going to
cheer for this boom this will be the
Internet of plastic waste this will be a
boom in asturias but all over the world
and particularly where poverty is worse
because that's where the rubbish is most
and that's the resource so I'm gonna
cheer for it and stand back to eat we're
in an era where so many people around
the world are craving a new regenerative
economy these big supply chains these
big industries to fundamentally
transform the strikes this is a giant
idea and you're gonna need a lot of
people cheering you on your way to make
it happen thank you for thank you thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]